today the legal cannabis industry is
worth about 20 billion dollars
and that's dwarfed by the illicit market
which is worth over 100 billion dollars
right now currently cannabis is
federally illegal
so states throughout the years starting
with california in 1996 have
slowly passed state laws that allow for
certain
legal markets medical marijuana is legal
in some form or another in about 40
states
some states only allow for the use of
cbd others allow for wide access to all
types of cannabis products to treat all
kinds of conditions
it's an industry with a lot of nuance
there are some pretty significant
changes on the horizon though for 2021
the senate is now
in the control of democrats and
democrats are very motivated to
change federal law so timeline of when
cannabis could be legalized on the
federal level it's still
up in the air but um it's gonna happen
sooner rather than later
the cannabis industry is growing while
the industry used to be mostly made up
of mom and pop shops
the biggest players are now public
companies with multi-billion dollar
market caps
this transformation makes sense
especially if you realize how much the
legal industry has grown in the last few
years
since 2014 the cannabis industry has
grown from 3.4 billion dollars in global
sales
to about 20 billion dollars last year
current estimates put legal cannabis
sales at more than 40 billion dollars by
2024.
beau wrigley is part of one of america's
classic
business dynasties the wrigley family
his great grandfather
and his namesake william wrigley started
the william wrigley company
in the late 1800s he started as a soap
company
very quickly he pivoted to chewing gum
beau's father worked and ran the company
until
the day he died literally in march 1999
and beau took it over when he was 35 and
he ran it until
2008 he sold the company to the mars
family
for 23 billion dollars after he sold the
family company
he became an investor and he has a bunch
of different investments in health care
and that kind of thing
what's interesting about beau is
cannabis was never part of his life he
didn't grow up smoking marijuana
one day the managing director of beau's
private equity
group came up to him and kind of
nervously
started asking like hey bo what do you
think about cannabis
and he said i have thoughts about it and
definitely not interested
but that said him and his managing
director kind of talked it out and
thought about it it's like okay well
i actually don't know much about it so
let's figure it out
wrigley realized what he thought he knew
about cannabis was wrong
he started to see it was a burgeoning
industry that had been unfairly
hamstrung by law and politics
he saw the change in consumer behavior
over 60 percent of americans are now in
favor of legalization
and the applications in healthcare as a
great opportunity
beau realized that people use cannabis
for
all different reasons you know people
use it to relax but also
there are legitimate medical uses so he
started
looking at it seriously and him and his
managing director started doing research
and
they identified one company stertera
wellness which is in florida
and they took a plane down to the
cultivation site which is
outside of tampa this is the first time
he's seen
one marijuana plant let alone an entire
grow facility full of them
he ended up leading a 65 million dollar
investment round into the company
and about a year later he took over as
ceo
a little bit after that they changed the
name to parallel forbes estimates
parallel makes
around 200 million dollars a year in
revenue and that the company is worth
at least two billion dollars with an
investor
like beau and a bunch of other high net
worth individuals
they're in a pretty interesting position
right now
he told me that he tried to smoke a
joint once
didn't really work he's not a smoker so
coming to this investment he he actually
smoked pop once in his life while
wrigley doesn't smoke cannabis
he does enjoy his own products one of
his favorite ways is
they have this nano emulsified product
it's basically like a hyper-concentrated
form that's in a little dropper and you
put some in a drink
so his go-to form of consumption
is to put a couple drops in a lacroix
parallel has several brands that sell to
a wide variety of consumers
from gen z to baby boomers parallel has
products for all of their customers
vaporizers edibles mints and drops
they even struck a licensing deal with
singer and entrepreneur jimmy buffett
parallel is also looking to develop thcv
which has the same euphoric effects as
thc
the main psychoactive compound in
cannabis but it is an appetite
suppressant
it would give you the euphoric feeling
without the
urge to eat wrigley wants to use
cannabis to improve sleep as well
kind of what beau envisions is a product
that he calls kind of an ambient killer
this is not an fda approved product but
it would be something over the counter
that could assist you in terms of a
sleep aid
[Music]
beau wrigley is really the classic
executive if you will
he ran his family's company and sold it
in
one of the deals of a lifetime and
if you were to ask when he sold the
family company you know is bill rigley
gonna
get into marijuana the answer would
definitely be no
but as you get to know him he is a very
thoughtful and visionary person
so he will approach something
with his own inherent ideas and biases
like anybody will but
he is of the mind to kind of challenge
those assumptions just the fact that
wrigley
is in the industry helped change how
people perceive
the cannabis industry
[Music]